hi in this module i'm going to talk
about gibbs sampling simple algorithm
for approximately computing marginal
probabilities and
so recall that a markov network is based
on a factor graph
and
a factor graph
gives a weight to every possible
assignment of variables in that vector
graph
and in a markov network we'll convert
that weight into a probability by first
computing
the normalization constant which is sum
over
uh all the assignments of the weight of
that assignment
divide by that normalization constant
and we get the probability of
assignment little x
so in this object tracking example
we see
we have a bunch of different assignments
their weights
the partition function in this case is
26 we divide each of these weights by 26
and we get
these probabilities
so the cool thing with markov networks
is that you can compute marginal
probability
and that's going to be our focus today
so marginal probability
is going to be focusing on one
particular variable x i and asking what
values could it take on
and to get that we're going to sum over
all possible assignments where x i does
actually equal
of the joint probability of that
assignment
and in this example
if you look
and ask for the probability of x2 equals
one you sum over all the rows where x
two one that gives you uh
point six two and if you ask for
x two equals two
either you're summing over the last two
rows and that gives you
so now let me present give sampling
there's a simple algorithm for
approximately computing these marginal
you could
iterate over all possible assignments
and compute but that would take
exponential time
so give sampling is going to follow the
template of local search where we're
going to go through each variable one at
a time and update them
but unlike iterated conditional modes
which we saw before give sampling is a
randomized algorithm tailored for the
purpose of computing
so let's present the algorithm
so
we're going to initialize the assignment
to some completely random
assignment
and then we're going to loop through
each of the variables until convergence
which i'll talk about a little bit later
we're going to
set
the assignment x i equals v
with this probability the probability of
x i equals v
given
x minus i equals
x minus i so this my x minus i notation
just refers to all the variables except
for x i
i'll come back to this in a second but
let me just highlight the kind of the
general flow of the algorithm so suppose
you have three variables if sampling is
going to try to sample x1 holding the
other ones fixed and now it's going to
move on to x2 holding the others fixed
and update x2 and then go to x3 and then
it's going to cycle back to x1 x2 x3 and
so
so now how do i sample
x i equals
so um
[Music]
here is one example
what we're going to do is we're going to
try uh assigning
x i equals v
and getting some
weight
so for every possible assignment of x2
i'm going to get some weight
and now remember in icm i would just
simply take the value that produce the
largest weight
but the main difference with gibb
sampling is that i'm going to take these
weights and i'm going to normalize them
to produce a probability again
normalizing is summing these values but
when i get five and dividing by five to
get probability point two point four
four
and now i'm going to sample x two equals
one of these values according to this
probability district
so you can visualize that sampling
process
by
the interval from 0 to 1
where i have a number of segments
representing the different possible
values of x2
and the length is uh exactly the
probability so probability of x2 equals
0 probability of x2 equals 1 and
probability of x2 equals 2.
and then i'm going to throw a
one-dimensional dart at this um at this
line i'm going to hit it somewhere and
i'm going to take whatever value
is
specified by that and
okay so now i have
a new value for
x2 here and now i proceed to the next
variable and
so
so that
produces a sequence of
samples
of the assignments
and the main remaining thing to do is to
aggregate them
so i'm going to
every time i go through this loop i'm
going to increment a counter
for variable i
of the particular value
that i i saw
okay so
and at the very end
i'm going to compute an estimate p hat
of
x i equals x little x i
and this is going to be simply the
normalized version of the count
so this is going to be the relative
frequency of
seeing a particular value little x i uh
compared to you know everything else
i've seen
but there's a lot of counting and
normalizing
so let's look at this demo to uh give us
a
more fuller sense what's going on okay
so here is the object tracking example i
have three variables and here i'm going
i can specify the query which is which
variable am i interested in calculating
the marginal of
and i'm going to run gibbs sampling here
and then at the beginning
i sample a variable x 1
given everything else so consider all
the possible values of x1
um i'm going to look at their
potentials or factors computer weight
normalize
to get a distribution and i'm going to
sample a value according to
these probabilities so this in this case
is just a coin flip i choose x1 equals
zero
and then i update my counter
so i'm recording that i saw
x2 equals ones once
okay
and then i'm going to move on to the
next variable x2 do the same thing
move to the next variable x3 and do the
same thing and i'm going to just cycle
for this for a moment you can see that
um
the the assignment which is depicted up
here is changing
um
and down here
um i can see that the count
of the number of times x1
x2 equals 1 has gone up to 25
um and now look i actually hit a
different value x i went to a
configuration where x2 equals two now
um
and then i might sample a little bit
more and they'll come back to one
and you can just watch this for a little
while and you can see over here that
these are the estimates of the marginal
probability of x2 based on the counts so
these numbers are simply these
normalized versions of these
so i'm going to speed this up a little
bit so let me do just a thousand steps
at a time
okay so now i have a val if i did a
thousand steps of gibbs sampling now i
have a lot of counts of x uh two equals
one some counts of x two equals two and
now you can see the probabilities are
kind of converging to something like 0.6
and 0.3 let me just hit a step a few
more times and you can see that these
probabilities are indeed converging to
0.61
which if you remember from here is
pretty close to the true marginal
probability
okay so
it seems you know at first gland kind of
a wild thing right so we're running this
algorithm it's just generating samples
left and right it's
kind of random and yet if i compute the
randomness is very carefully are
orchestrated so that when i sum things
up properly i actually get the right
answer out
so let me now go to the image de-noising
example so here the goal is you're given
a noisy image clean it up and in our
simplified version
i have
x i which represents the
clean pixel value
which i don't know
a subset of the pixels are observed so
for example these um in green here
and i'm going to clamp those pixel
values to the observed value and then i
have a
factor
that says neighboring pixels are twice
as likely to be the same than different
so let's do give sampling in this image
noise in case so what give sampling
would do is it's going to sweep across
the image
and sample each variable condition on
the left
so
suppose
i'm landing on this particular
pixel value and i'm trying to figure out
what should its value be
so again i look at the possible values
it could be zero or one and for each
value i'm going to compute a weight
so
remember from icm that i actually don't
need to
compute the weight of the entire
assignment i just only need to look at
the factors which are dependent on this
value
okay so
let's consider v equals zero
so here if i put zero here that means
this potential is going to be happy
because years agree and i'm gonna get a
two
um
and this one is going to disagree
this one's going to disagree on this one
so the weight is 2 times 1 times 1 times
1 which is
so now if i try to put a 1 in this
position
now
um this uh potential says one while the
others say two
so now that has a weight of eight
so now to get the probability of x i
equals v
given everything else i'm simply going
to sum up and normalize so i have 2 and
8 here the normalization constant
is 10. so i get probabilities 0.2 and
0.8
now given this distribution i'm going to
set
this value to
1 with probability of 0.8 and 0 with
probability 0.2
and then i'm going to keep on going
so here is a fun little demo of give
sampling for image noise that runs in
your browser
okay so the idea is that here is an
image and if you
uh hit control enter here
um you'll see that this is the input to
the system so we have black pixels and
red pixels these are the observed pixels
and white
pixels are unobserved and these are the
ones that we want to fill in
so there's a bunch of settings which
i'll talk to about in a second but if
you click here you can see how get a
feeling for what give sampling is doing
each frame here each iteration is a full
pass over all
the pixels and you can see that it's
kind of dancing around because it's
trying to explore
different uh assignments
so one thing you can do is um you can
set show marginals equals true
and what this does is that instead of
visualizing the assignment at a
particular iteration for each of his
pixel here i'm actually visualizing the
marginal probability estimate so this is
in general going to be a number between
0 and 1 which is represented as a shade
between black and red here
so this in some sense is the kind of
best guess at what the reconstruction
is
so there are a number of things you can
play with so for example the fraction of
missing pixels if i reduce this to let's
say 0.3
then
you know the problem becomes easier and
you can see that the reconstruction gets
some you know pretty reasonable
results another fun thing you can play
with is um well actually let me let me
bring down the map
bring up the missing fraction to one
okay so that means i don't see any pixel
so
here um this is just going to be
actually i mean let me do
show margins equals false
oops
so here you can see kind of just blind
samples from
the model
okay and
if i pop up the coherence if i bump it
down
um then you'll see kind of a more random
pattern
if i bump it up to 10
then you'll see kind of more coherence
so remember this is kind of like the
phase transitions that we saw for the
easy
okay so i will let you
play with this on your phone
let me just conclude here uh actually
one thing before we
so
let me try to go back to iterated
conditional modes and compare that with
give samples both of them have the same
kind of template you're working with
complete assignments and you're going
through each variable and updating the
assignment to that variable one at a
time
but there's a few differences here
one the first salient one is that
idea of conditional modes was for
solving csps where we're trying to find
the maximum weight assignment dip
sampling is for markup networks where
we're trying to compute marginal
probabilities
so as a consequence for icm
we at each step we're choosing the value
to sign to a variable which maximizes
its weight whereas in give sampling
we're
using the weights to form a distribution
and sampling from that distribution
in icm we notice that
the algorithm does converge but often to
a local optimum which is not the best
maximum weight assignment
for gift sampling
as you can see from these samples
there's no traditional notions of
convergence then the samples are going
to keep on changing and keep on changing
so the iterates are not the ones which
are converging what is actually going to
converge are the marginal estimates
and
in under some technical assumptions
these estimates are actually going to
converge to the correct answer
we saw that for object tracking it did a
pretty good job there
um but there were some kind of technical
conditions um one sufficient condition
is that all the weights uh be
positive
but more
uh generally what we need is that for
the probability of going from one
assignment to another assignment via
give sampling has positive probability
because if you have two disconnected um
regions then you can't if you start keep
sampling at one particular point then
you will never reach the other point
so one important caveat is skip sampling
is wonderful but
it in the worst case it does take
exponential time so these are really
computing margin probabilities is a
really hard problem and gibb sampling is
just you know a heuristic with some
nice
asymptotic guarantee
so wrapping up
um we looked at
computing the marginal probabilities of
a markov network
and we saw that gibbs sampling did this
by sampling one variable at a time
and it counts visitations
to each of the values for a given
variable
and it's one of these kind of
astonishing things that give sampling
is so carefully constructed that it
actually kind of works and you can prove
lots of interesting theorems about it
finally gibbs family is just the first
taste of a much more broad class of
techniques called markov chain monte
carlo which are used to
produce
much kind of richer ways of estimating
probabilities in markup
all right that's the end of this module